energy security of course has been at
the center of this entire conflict and
joining us now from a very energy-rich
state louisiana senator bill cassidy
senator welcome to you and welcome back
to fox news sunday great to see you
hey thanks for having me so you just saw
my interview with pentagon press
secretary john kirby on the escalating
tensions with russia and ukraine what
was your takeaway from what you just
heard sir
yeah
this is a culmination of the united
states kind of d-army when it comes to
energy diplomacy
if think about it less than a year ago
under the previous administration we
were not only energy independent but
poised to become the to have the ability
to make the eu
energy independent in less than a year
we've lost that ability and so now
russia has the leverage over the eu
in terms of energy supply in order to
kind of blackmail them into turning a
blind eye you could argue they're trying
not to but germany's response has been
quite muted to this
apparently pending
pending invasion i would say that this
is a culmination of a failed energy
geopolitical policy senator on that note
general keane and others have said well
is it as much leverage as as we make it
out to be considering that gas is not
yet flowing through that nordstrom to
pipeline
it's not currently a revenue source for
vladimir putin so is it as much leverage
as many are making it out to be that
pipeline
there's still north stream one and
they're still liquefied natural gas
shipments in in two and by the way
energy prices are much higher in europe
right now than they traditionally are
and that's having an impact on the
individual's pocketbook and upon their
economy so we've already seen a kind of
hint of that leverage and it could
obviously increase should the russians
decide to further exploit all right
senator the president is strongly
encouraging meanwhile and you just heard
us talk about this a moment ago
encouraging americans in ukraine to
leave as soon as possible and says that
there is no prospect for a u.s
military-led evacuation from inside
ukraine
so
should the u.s be doing more about this
i agree with the president a hundred
percent use some common sense we should
not be endangering our soldiers or
marines etc because somebody decides not
to evacuate until after the fact
get out if there's a pending invasion
use common sense leave
all right senator the president this
week meanwhile vowed to end that
nordstrom 2 pipeline if russia invades
ukraine germany said it is united with
the u.s in that decision he did so
standing next to president biden at the
white house so if that pipeline as we
just discussed remains halted germany
will lean on other foreign nations as
you well know for a significant amount
of their energy needs so what can we be
doing as a country today knowing the
resources that we have and can tap into
as you just mentioned what can we be
doing to prepare for what will likely be
an energy crisis in europe if russia
does invade
we must resume
using america's resources ramping them
up in order to provide or replace that
which russia would provide by the way
that means beginning to lease in the
outer continental shelf off louisiana
allowing development of oil and natural
gas
and public lands on the inland and
speeding up permitting for the lng
export facilities and pipelines that are
currently not occurring it could also
include by the way
permitting for the renewables to be able
to ship their electrons right now this
administration is putting in amber
the ability of the u.s
to to expand its energy supply that's
why we're paying more for gas and
natural gas it's why the eu is we have
to ease that not only for ourselves but
also for the eu
your home state of louisiana sir
provides more natural gas exports than
any other u.s state and of course we
know you have access to a whole lot more
you and a few other republican senators
met this week with the eu commissioner
for energy were there any promises made
that we will be able to meet europe's
energy needs in the future
senators cannot promise if the
administration slow walks everything by
every means possible to decrease u.s
energy production
now the administration can take laws
that are on the book interpret them in
such a way
sometimes in direct conflict with the
stated means of the law to slow down
production
that's what this administration is doing
they're doing it in the name of lowering
carbon intensity so now germany's
burning coal instead of natural gas not
only are we getting more carbon
intensity but we're also putting our
european allies
at threat of economic downturn and
allowing them to be leveraged by russia
this administration's
energy policy is a failure in terms of
the climate in terms of national
security the economy in terms of you
name it
senator i want to move on to the great
mass debate we saw a lot of it this week
and indeed this week we saw democrat and
republican governors alike either
dropping or winding down their indoor or
school mass mandates in your state right
now louisiana the governor has
encouraged mask wearing there but says
schools can opt out of masks as long as
the schools follow cdc quarantine
guidelines yet the cdc and the white
house are still recommending wearing
masks in high transmission areas i want
to show you a map of louisiana
department of health provided this it
indicates community risk right now is
very high all over the state so should
kids be wearing masks in louisiana
schools sir
we have we have to follow the science if
the science says that mask is only of
marginal benefit but that the cost to
the child is of more than marginal cost
then we have to follow the science
and i'll just say that because clearly
what has happened over the last year
children have suffered from being locked
out of school and some say from wearing
the mask let's follow the signs i'm a
doc
that's what i believe that's what we
should do
and that's what makes you a very unique
senator right having that md we've seen
some major battles playing out over who
has final say on mass mandates for the
children schools or the governors in
your home state school mass mandate
decisions are left up to local school
districts is that the right approach
senator or should governors be able to
supersede local authorities as we've
seen recently in states like virginia
i'm a conservative i think that he or
she who governs closest to those
governed governs best so i do think that
should be a local decision i say that as
a rocked rib conservative
great to hear from you senator joining
us from the great state of louisiana
senator cassidy thank you very much